JASON SILVA: So there's
a fantastic interview
with George Carlin,
when he's talking
about how he gets some
of his greatest ideas
and how he achieved
such brilliance
in his comedy and such success.
And so we talked
about this concept
known as psycho-cybernetics.
And psycho-cybernetics has to
do with the way of programming
your brain to exploit its
pattern recognizing capacities.
In other words, the brain
is a goal seeking mechanism,
he says.
And so he talks about
creating a set of impressions
in your brain, sort
pre-decide the kind
of patterns that's going to
be on the lookout for us.
So the first idea,
of course, is come up
with an idea, think of a
joke, come up with an insight.
There's the initial impression,
the initial creative thought.
So impression number one
is the moment you of it.
impression number two
is to write it down.
Record it.
Transcribe it.
That's impression number two.
Impression number three
is review your notes later
in the day.
Go through the things
you thought about.
Look at the digital paper trail
of everything you wrote down
and everything you thought of.
And then after those
three impressions,
the initial thought,
the writing it down,
and the reflecting
upon later, you've
imprinted in your
brain that metapattern.
And the later on, that day,
that week, that whatever,
you're going to start
connecting the dots.
Everywhere you go,
you're going to have
serendipitous encounters
with things that are
connected to that initial idea.
Go to a bookstore and every
book you open to any single page
will review a clue.
And it's essentially,
again, you're
essentially priming
your brain to find
patterns and connections
to this particular thing.
It's a way of cultivating
curiosity and cultivating
sort of mind maps and
neural networks in a way.
And then again, you find
that the world is indeed
full of clues and you can
read your way through it.
You have to figure out
what you're looking for.
And you've got a program
that into your subconscious.
So that's the
psycho-cybernetics.